Chancellor in your head of the National
Security Council here clearly there are
a lot of preparations being made for the
battle for mosul so-called are the
kurdish peshmerga going to participate
in that definitely we have looked at the
plan the plan has been prepared and
we've reviewed the plan and definitely
person areas are going to participate
but of course there will be some
limitations of how far they can go
what are those limitations there are
some geographical limitations that we
don't want to to go to the areas that
will probably create some sensitivities
so but basically on the plan it's very
clear how far the peshmerga's can go
there are sensitivities in Mosul because
of the cultural and ethnic sectarian
makeup of that city through one of those
sensitivities is that the Shia militias
from Iraq may be part of this battle
plan what assurances do you have that
that won't be the case see you're right
I mean this sensitivities I have to be
taken into consideration the components
of Mosul is very mixed you have very
different people of different
backgrounds Aetna
ethnic groups religious groups so you
have to be considerate of how
comfortable these people are going to be
with the incoming liberating force some
of the forces that are not well accepted
by the local communities must not try to
get into the city basically to not
irritate the population or to not push
them to collaborate with Isis do you
believe I have no reason not to believe
has the Peshmerga been given the
resources it needs to be an effective
partner
we have always asked for more effective
weapons and resources to the peshmerga's
unfortunately they haven't been given
what they have asked for or what they
have deserve
especially in terms of giving protecting
gears to the peshmerga's or the kind of
equipments that they needed to quickly
defeat Isis kind of weapons that they
needed unfortunately there weren't there
for the peshmergas but peshmerga's were
very determined to fight and defeat
defeat Isis of course they did but it
was a you know a heavy cost and of
course we had many casualties of course
with more adequate better equipments our
casualties would have been much less and
I think the enemy would have been
defeated much quicker so do you feel
used as Kurds no we don't feel used but
we feel as part of this coalition
against terrorism that the international
community should have had more or felt
more responsible to providing what the
peshmerga's needed as the peshmerga's
are fighting not only for their own
cause but on behalf of the rest of the
world why do you think they've been so
reluctant to help there are some you
know like I said political sensitivities
is perhaps but I think these are they
shouldn't have been used as an excuse
because this is a war against terror and
terror is a problem that the whole world
is facing not helping the peshmerga's to
the extent that they needed to be
supported for whatever excuse or reasons
they might come up with I think is not
it's not fair or not logical to know to
be correct however we do understand that
perhaps there are some regional players
that may not be very happy and satisfied
with the kind of weapons that
peshmerga's receive as they think that
the strength of pesh MERGA is not in
their best interest which again I would
definitely argue that that's not the
correct calculation of how things are
because the strength of pesh MERGA is
here the strength of kurdistan
definitely is going to help not only
Iraq but the entire region
when you say regional players do you
mean
predominantly turkey and there's lesser
extent Iran I don't want to name any
country but basically the original
players are very obvious you know in all
the countries that are here and what
preparations are you making for what
some people have wound make could be in
a humanitarian catastrophe we've talked
to the UN we've talked to the coalition
forces we have talked to back that of
course and here in the KRG we've done
all we can so far you know you you know
that we are we are hosting about two
million IDPs and refugees from the rest
of Iraq and also from Syria we expect a
big inflow of people from also coming in
toward here to Kurdistan so there are
camps have been set up but of course we
can provide them shelter we can provide
them security but KRG doesn't have the
capability to take care of them and
provide all the needs for this large
number of people that are coming in you
talk about a short campaign that would
be everybody's preference in Mosul but
the pattern in Fallujah Ramadi is that
it could take years is that something
that you think is conceivable with the
city this big I think it's going to be a
difficult war in Mosul based on the
information that we have they are
preparing to fight very fiercely inside
the city they are digging tunnels they
are preparing themselves to find but at
the end during the war I know you never
know what happens so they could collapse
you don't know and that's what we hope
but we have to be prepared for the worst
and for a long battle doesn't that risk
besieging Mosul and hurting the civilian
population over a longer period well you
know masala has been besieged anyway
based no no besides what Isis has been
trying to provide and do for the people
or let people do for themselves that
that's a better phrase they haven't
allowed any any assistance or any wanted
to go and reach the civil population so
in any case and I mean it's a hard time
to begin with if we talk about where the
Peshmerga the KRG forces are now
they are beyond what used to be your
frontier if you like with Iraq will you
give that territory back there's been
retaken it like I said let's let's be
clear on this we don't think that we
have taken anyone's land we have just
reclaimed what this initially been ours
now we have the chance to make it right
we have made it right and we are going
to defend it so you're not gonna move
absolutely not in that context whether
you're looking at Mosul an amber
province at the relationship with
Kurdistan isn't
Iraq going to face more civil wars even
after the defeat of Isis well let's
let's be honest
Isis is just a by-product it's just a
result of some much bigger problems the
root cause of this problem is political
to begin with if Iraq had worked for the
last hundred years we wouldn't have had
all these problems it didn't work it has
never been peaceful or safe not you know
for their own people or the neighbors so
if you know the mistakes have been made
in the past and now it's time for the
world to realize that there is the time
to look for new approaches for new
solutions if things are not approached
that way then expect problems to
continue expect terrorist organizations
like Isis to emerge again remember I
mean before Isis there was al Qaeda
so after Isis there could be something
else that has the root causes have to be
addressed and and the real problems have
to be solved in order to prevent the the
rise of this sort of extremist
radicalized organizations imagine if if
political structure worked there could
have been economic prosperity they could
have been social order they could have
been peace among all the people so there
would be there would be security
everywhere so there would be no vacuum
for these radical as terrorist
organizations to come and grow